Deputy Coles:
You're free to go.
♪♪
Justin Timberlake:
I play Eddie Palmer, who comes
back home from twelve years of being in prison...
♪♪
Justin:
to find everything a bit
different.
You just got to get yourself back
out there.
So many people are just discarded
after they come out of prison.
You were All-USA player two years
in a row.
(Whistle blowing)
Yes, sir.
If I can't get a job sweeping
floors,
what am I supposed to do?
While trying to find myself I
stumble upon, Sam.
There's something seriously
wrong with that kid.
I think I can spice that up a
little.
Vivian:
His momma took off again.
Sam's mother is battling a
pretty extreme drug addiction.
You wouldn't know where Shelly
is?
Your guess is as good as mine.
You sure you can hang on to
him for a little bit longer?
Hey Palmer.
Cheryl Guerriero:
You have this kid who is just
content in being who he is.
Cheers!
Cheryl Guerriero:
He just does what feels natural.
He dresses a certain way
and he is very comfortable in his
own skin.
-Quite an outfit.
-Thanks!
Justin:
My character sees that he can
make a difference in this child’s life...
You think maybe we oughta put
something else in there today?
Eddie:
Grab that loaf of bread.
...and finds his way through
that action.
Sam, you’re doing good, huh?
Real good.
Fisher Stevens:
This boy gives Palmer
self-esteem really and Palmer
gives this boy a father.
(Crying)
Who did this to you Sam?
It’s ok, you can tell us.
Maggie:
What are you going to do...
...beat up everyone that picks on
him?
You ain’t nothing but a
criminal.
Sheriff Coles:
You just couldn’t stay out of
trouble, could you?
PALMER!!!
Alisha Wainwright:
It's about the possibility of
someone who
through adversity can come out
the other side and be better for
it.
Palmer:
I know what it feels like to be
left alone.
I will not abandon that boy.
This is a story about
redemption, acceptance, and
love.
Second chances are possible and
you can be whoever you want to
be.
Palmer:
Truth is, I haven't felt like I
was good at anything
Palmer:
in a long time, until Sam.